(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU A TOPIC
PULLED FROM THE CLASSY BEST IN
THE BIZ TWEETS OF MILLIONAIRE
PRICK DONALD TRUMP.
(LAUGHTER)
AND YOU TELL ME--
>> DOES HE HAVE TIME TO TWEET?
HIS HAIR IS LIKE GANDOLFINI'S
BREATHING IN THE SOPRANOS.
IT'S ITS OWN CHARACTER.
>> Chris: I MEAN, SERIOUSLY, THE
HAIR COULD HAVE ITS OWN TWITTER
ACCOUNT AT THIS POINT.
SO YOU GUYS HAVE TO TELL US IF
HE LIKES A THING, HIRED OR IF HE
HATES THE THING THAT I'M GOING
TO MENTION, FIRED.
OKAY, FIRST ONE.
HOW DO YOU THINK THE OVERLORD
OF TRUMP TOWER FEELS ABOUT POPE
FRANCIS-- FIRED OR HIRED?
YES, AL MADRIGAL.
>> HE IS DEFINITELY FIRED.
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
I BELIEVE THAT HE IS IN FACT,
HIRED.
HE LIKES THE POPE.
THE NEW POPE IS A HUMBLE
MAN, VERY MUCH LIKE ME WHICH
PROBABLY EXPLAINS WHY I LIKE HIM
SO MUCH.
>> YEAH.
I'M SO HUMBLE I TWEET ABOUT HOW
HUMBLE I AM.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: HEY, ON SECOND
THOUGHT, (BLEEP) THE POPE, I'M
DONALD TRUMP!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE, HOW DOES
THE POPE FEEL ABOUT MODERN
FAMILY?
THE POPE...
(LAUGHTER)
>> YOU KNOW HOW HE FEELS ABOUT
IT?
HE SAYS YEAH.
>> Chris: I'M SORRY.
HOW DOES DONALD TRUMP, THE
DOUCHE POPE, FEEL ABOUT MODERN
FAMILY?
YES, RANDY.
>> I THINK HE DOESN'T LIKE IT.
HE DOESN'T LIKE IT.
>> Chris: FIRED, DOES NOT LIKE
IT.
WHY EVEN APOLOGIZE AT THAT
POINT?
>> AND HE DOES KNOW THAT HIS